marvin petit l'un des boxeurs les plus
prometteurs de sa génération à 25 ans
l'élan courtois déjà à son actif deux
titres de championnes fronton a remporté
en décembre 2015 cirque d'hiver contre
sylvain chapelle une consécration pour
ce boxeur qui a débuté par la boxe pieds
poings à versailles et enfin monsieur
c'est la boxe tout petit j'ai déjà dès
l'âge de 9 ans 9 en mi temps 8 en
innovant et du coup je fais que mon
petit cousin et un jour mon père m'a dit
je vais te casser la gueule un peu à 12
ans le boxeur a décidé de se lancer dans
la boxe anglaise et de faire confiance à
la team farruggia installait il encourt
le club créé en 1998 à façonner des
dizaines de champion d'europe et des
champions du monde
marvin est aujourd'hui entraînée par
tanguy farruggia c'est un entraîneur dur
et c'est ce qu'il fallait il était
toujours sans nous faire offert quand
c'était pas bien revenu en faisait même
si ç'a duré une demi heure 40 minutes on
leur faisait écouter ce qu'ils disent
pour réaliser ses rêves marvin petit
s'entraîne du lundi au vendredi à la
proche d'un combat le sportif intensifie
ses séances jusqu'à 4h sur l'objectif
ressemble à l'hymne de ses idoles
l'américain mike tyson l'ancien champion
du monde des poids lourds
parce que c'était quelqu'un de
j'aime bien c'était quelqu'un de
guerrier qu'on veut et qui lâche rien la
méchanceté et l'agressivité en fait
quand je regarde des vidéos c'est fait
c'est quand j'étais blessé
agressif comme lui il est peut-être
moins agressif mais il cherche pas que
le puncheur en boxe il cherche à amener
la à l'adversaire l'échec de provoquer
la faute à l'adversaire pour le touché
marine petit devrait remettre les gants
compétition novembre prochain pour un
championnat européen l'occasion de
marquer encore un peu plus l'histoire de
la boxe française